good day and welcome to nature's returns
a webinar speaker series hosted by the
Yale Center for business and the
environment my name is Andrew woo and I
will be your host for today's webinar
titled protecting nature landscape scale
conservation in the United States the
Yale Center for business and the
environment is pleased to continue
dangerous returns a webinar series that
addresses the growing importance of
ecosystem service valuation and
investment each presentation is recorded
and available on a Yale iTunes U channel
we are pleased to have Peter Howell with
us today Peter Howell serves as the
executive vice president of conservation
capital at the open space Institute
previously Howell was the program
director for the environment at the
doors Duke Charitable Foundation where
you oversaw the distribution of almost
100 million dollars for land
conservation in the United States he
also worked as a program officer at the
Wallace funds directing an 18 million
dollar national initiative focused on
creating and improving urban parks today
Howell will discuss his work at the open
space Institute a conservation
organization that focuses on landscape
scale conservation throughout the
eastern United States through recent
project spearheaded by OSI Howell will
illustrate the challenges and
opportunities that landscape scale
conservation presents and share his
insights on current trends regarding
conservation in the United States before
we begin the presentation we would like
to remind our listeners that questions
are welcomed and will be directed to our
speaker at the conclusion of the talk
you can type questions directly into the
gotomeeting chat window and with that we
welcome Peter Howell to nature's returns
thank you Andrew it's a pleasure to be
here and to participate in this
gathering OSI has a long association
with Yale we have several graduates of
the College two of my colleagues Abby
Weinberg and Jennifer Melville are
graduates of the forestry school so it's
my pleasure to be part of this
illustrious community
I look forward to sharing insights about
the topic both from the work that I have
done over the past 12 years here at OSI
as well as some insights from my earlier
work on the other side of the aisle
working in the foundation community so
without further ado our agenda a little
bit about us then I really want to focus
on two case studies they're very
different in nature to illustrate some
of the themes about the challenges
opportunities around large landscape
conservation I'd like to talk in a
little bit about what the current
context is and to close with some
reflections on current initiatives
including a number of interesting
transactions and then take questions and
see if there's discussion OSI for those
of you who don't know us briefly we were
founded in nineteen seventy-four our
mission is to protect scenic natural
historic landscapes to provide public
enjoyment conserve habitat and working
lands and sustain communities we employ
a couple of strategies to achieve our
mission principally in New York but
increasingly elsewhere we engage in
direct acquisition of land and easements
second the program that I run focuses on
providing funding both through loans and
grants to help other land Trust's and
selected landscapes of the East to do
their work we fund and also conduct
research on related issues around land
conservation third we support advocacy
efforts principally around public
funding in new york state and federally
and support efforts to engage grassroots
environmental leaders and organizations
here in New York where do we work
principally in the eastern United States
our home where we've worked for 40 years
and continued New York State principally
in the in the Hudson Valley north of New
York but into the cab skills and up into
the Adirondacks we also work in selected
states in New England all
so a little bit in the central
appalachian and increasingly in the
southeast with a focus in the southern
Appalachians in particular in the
southern Cumberlands in the Alabama
Georgia Tennessee area and on the coast
of South Carolina our work in the east
has included a number of elements we've
helped to protect about a hundred and
ten thousand acres principally in New
York but most recently in South Carolina
and in New Jersey we've helped to
facilitate the protection outside New
York of about 2.2 million acres from
Quebec to Alabama and in the process
have distributed about a hundred and ten
million dollars to regional national
regional local Land Trust through a mix
of loans and grants we do this in
selected geographies through capital
funds that include they make grant and
loan funds available to date we have a
about 30 million dollars that we are
playing with to distribute in these
geographies and importantly to both
establish our funds and to complement
them we conduct research and science on
promising strategies to get the scale
and also support planning and research
efforts that are complementary to land
acquisition there are two issues in
particular that we are working on that I
think rise to a landscape scale one is
our resilient landscape initiative which
is a 12 million dollar initiative
capitalized by the doors foundation we
wrkn selected geographies to provide
capital support for land transactions to
protect resilient habitats using science
developed by Mark Anderson and his
colleagues at the Nature Conservancy and
we're working princely in the Northeast
to be expanded to the southeast and in
the Delaware River watersheds the
Delaware River Basin 14,000 mile area
encompassing the states of New York New
Jersey Pennsylvania and Delaware we are
engaged in similar pursuits but to
protect water quality through land
protection and complementary support for
research and planning and education
geographically shown here this
sites that we're working in that some of
you may know are in yellow in New
England and a one site and the southern
Cumberlands in the southeast with two
more sites to be added in the coming
months tonight we are releasing the
second round of our RFP program for
capital and planning grants or catalyst
grants in that blue area the Delaware
River Basin that's essentially us let me
pivot now to the concept of large
landscape conservation I think as I
won't belabor these points I think that
most people on the call are probably
familiar with the fact that landscape
scale conservation has become quite
popular it has taken really leaps
forward in recent years and propelling
this change is the recognition within
the science community of the importance
of large-scale ecological processes and
that a purely species based approach is
not sufficient I'll touch a little bit
on some of this emerging science of
ecological resiliency won't touch on it
much actually but suffice it to say that
with climate change we're aware that
Roger is bigger and can facilitate
wildlife adaptation on a warming climate
planet there's also a recognition that a
regional scale is necessary to address
the key drivers of habitat loss
including development land use change
forest fragmentation and invasive
species finally there's growing interest
in the academic and policy community in
large landscape conservation the Fish
and Wildlife Services landscape
conservation cooperatives are but one
example of that landscape scale approach
finally as I'll touch on and as we've
learned in the northern forest there is
a increased supply of private capital
although a particularly investment
capital that can be deployed for
conservation at scale one of the things
that's most graphic to us and those of
you in the land trust community is the
increasing scale and scope of land
Trust's we see it in this increasing
larger regional visions of land Trust's
in New England that are graphically
Illustrated on this map that shows the
regional conservation partnerships these
have cropped up in New England heisted a
connecticut-based organization with whom
we work has played a pivotal role in
facilitating the growth of these rcps
today there are 40 of these rcps that
cover about sixty percent of New England
they typically are aggregations of land
Trust's communities agencies public
agencies that are focused on regional
priorities and are committed to
collaborating to move beyond purely town
or local priority and we've seen this in
other parts of the country but it's most
graphically Illustrated here in our own
but let me pivot to the two case studies
that I wanted to share with you and the
first is in New York State where we have
worked as I said for 40 years in the
second will drive us further north into
the northern forest the shower Gong
Ridge there is a globally rare ecosystem
and ecologically resilient landscape and
a recreational mecca this is where ye
sridhar began his climbing career in the
1950s and we're novice and expert
climbers alike continue to flock I'm
indebted in the following slides to my
colleague Bob anderberg an accomplished
climber hurt himself who has translated
his love for the region into one of os
eyes most successful and enduring
initiatives and he's not done as you'll
see this is the shower gunk shown here
in the inset map OSI and our partners
have been protecting land on this Ridge
for three decades expanding and
connecting the existing public lands
shown in dark green here principally
state park and units the ridge is part
of an overall ridge and valley system
that stretches down to the Chitty Chitty
Ridge in Pennsylvania up into the
highlands in Connecticut it's a key link
really in the overall Appalachian train
that stretches from southeastern Canada
or Maine all the way down to Alabama
to date OSI is protected almost 33,000
acres of land in 133 separate parcels
the majority along the ridge the
remainder of farmland in the valley
we've done this at a total cost of about
85 million dollars OSI at the end of the
day will have left about 60 million
dollars of our own money in the ground
the remainder has been or will be
recovered from sale of land to
government some private landowners and
contributions by philanthropy OSI has
often played a bridge road here
acquiring a holding land until public
funding could be arranged the land
typically where it's been conveyed into
public ownership is owned by the state
several other of our partners include
local land Trust's and the private
mohonk preserve we've doubled the size
of the Mohawk state preserve people
shown here walking on some of the
carriage roads that are part of that
park we've added 11,000 acres to seven
different state forests we've helped to
create campsites and catalyze investment
in existing declining Park
infrastructure we're credited in large
part or in some part to helping to
stimulate visitation to some of the
parks including minnewaska on Sam's
point and the private mahant preserve
these units together account for about
15 million dollars annually in direct
revenue and it's estimated that that has
about a two to three multiplier more of
more revenue that goes in in directly
into the local economy so we've helped
to expand some beautiful breathtaking
places like this the Peter skill
conservation area that we added to at
the same time we've worked off the ridge
while our main focus has been the ridge
we've also realized the importance of
protecting land in the valley to help
channel development to more appropriate
places and to preserve viewsheds and
help maintain farming of the 32,000
acres protected to date we preserved
about 4,000 acres of farmland
throughout right purchases and easements
we've also least some of this land for a
farm incubator a site of which is shown
here to help new farmers get a foothold
in the business over time we've realized
three major goals for our work shown
basically by some of these circles the
first is obviously we want to protect
the entire 50 mile length of the shala
Gong Ridge that is shown here we want to
create a conservation quarter to the
catskills which is can almost be created
here through a land bridge we also want
to connect conservation we've achieved
here down to this the town of you pulse
here and many of our targets have
included some of the areas right here
where we saw to buy buffers or additions
in and around these existing lands going
forward we have a target of almost 40
100 acres 25 different parcels that will
achieve the goals is outlined in these
circles one of the major a big part of
our work increasingly is to improve
public access to these recreational
resources that we've helped to create
and to strengthen the amenity based
economy that they support shown here are
a number of things I just want to
illustrate one that's particularly
visually appealing to look at and fun to
walk across and that's the rosendale
trestle this involved are helping to
transfer the land on either side for
creation of the walkway over this
railroad trestle it goes over the hudson
actually it's become an extraordinary
community asset it's facilitating
increased economic activity through
recreation and tourism one of our
biggest efforts though is in designing
enhancing the trail networks that exist
in and around these priceless resources
and I want to direct your attention
really over more to the right arm where
the oval that stretches into New Paltz
this is where one of the most exciting
efforts that we're engaged in is taking
place our vision is to create trail
through the various preserved lands that
are shown in green here that will link
new pulse at the bottom here to the
mohonk preserve in minnewaska shown up
in the distance a week ago we've groomed
8 miles of trails on land that we own
here and the local high school cross
country ski team began practicing there
along with others helping to create a
new constituency to conservation in this
region of course we're not sure how many
more winters will be like this one so we
see this as a trail for biking and
hiking not just skiing and thus this
landscape shown here has been one of the
most important for OSI and it's been one
of our best examples of achieving scale
what are the lessons first we've we've
protected this place incrementally and
through an aggregation process that is
prototypical of how most regional land
trusts work and one can look at that and
say well if we had more money why
couldn't we have done in 10 years what
we should have been able to put what
we've done in 30 and the question is yes
the answer is that's possible but time
actually is essential to achieving
credibility and integrating conservation
with community goals good conservation
offer often occurs in a stepwise fashion
where you can learn from your successes
and also your mistakes even with time to
gain credibility and even with staff
rooted in the community as we have we
sometimes have been a target of
criticism for people who think
government shouldn't own land or that a
non-profit is engaged in the land grab
and you get marked when you work at
scale if you work at postage stamp-sized
conservation you don't get marked so so
we've been a target at end places and
yet at the same time some of what this
aggregation has taught us is the
importance of building relationships and
building successive relationships with
funders this effort has been funded
primarily by public agencies so there's
been growing philanthropic interest
there's been less opportunity for
investors and this will contrast with
what I'll talk about in a little while
because there's little return on these
landscapes as there are on forested
landscapes of course there is potential
for compatible development but the
reputation risk there can be significant
so we've relied on creative bridge
financing and pris to get our work done
but we've not partnered with investors /
say a final lesson has been the
complementing our acquisition with a
focus on trails and park development has
actually increased the funding and
constituency for our work and has
broadened the base of support for what
we do in this region let me turn to my
second case study which is getting to
scale in a very different kind of
geography the northern forest and I want
to describe our work here over a decade
which is focused on supporting large
landscape conservation and the lessons
we've learned we played a very different
role here that of re grantor lender and
researcher as opposed to being a direct
acquisition agent instead of investing
our own money we were critical in
bringing other people's money in this
case foundations outside outside the
region into the northern forest this is
a region that when you look at it in its
entirety is one of the largest intact
broadleaf forests in the world this area
including Canada is about fifty hundred
fifty eight million acres of temperate
forests it's a region of large
unfragmented blocks of forest land with
moderate biodiversity much of it though
in the US has been cut over its second
in some cases third growth for us though
you can find some amazing tracks of
old-growth forests if you look for them
vast expanse is a forest land a lot of
it's flat as you see here in Maine
except for those iconic mountains the
whites the Adirondacks the greens and of
course guitar
this is an area that has a fair amount
of protection shown here in beige in
Canada these are Crown lands yet they
are akin to BLM or Bureau of Land
Management lands out West where multiple
use is permitted and sometimes there's
significant extraction activity on the
US side though with the exception of
some of the mountainous areas I
mentioned there were significantly less
protection and this was one of the
reasons that we were attracted to this
region in 2001 the low level of
protection that combined with the
seismic change and forest land ownership
that was just beginning to take place as
large industrial timber land owners
began to divest of their holdings
millions of acres were poised to change
hands and this was a copper conservation
opportunity that we sought to seize upon
challenge how to determine which were
the most important lands to protect
established a capital fund with 12
million dollars to fund land and
easements our goals initially were
modest we thought we would conserve
80,000 acres and leveraged perhaps 40
million dollars in other matching funds
after about ten years our successes far
exceeded those we helped to facilitate
the protection of about 2 million acres
of land eighty percent of it was working
for us leveraged at least about 250
million in other matching thongs
principally federal and state of public
funds those significant philanthropic
funds in Maine we completed a number of
signature transactions I'll touch on one
or two and supported the development of
several innovative financing tools along
with conducting research on issues such
as forest fragmentation working for
assessments and a financial analysis of
Tom Cruise and plum creek's proposed
development for the Moosehead Lake
Region in May this is what the world
looked like in 1997 he protected land
centered around some of those iconic
places I mentioned this is what the
world looked like after we were done
through the support of about twenty
three projects through a mix of grants
and loans so you can see there was a
significant amount of conservation that
was added particularly in down east
lakes in this region here also in
northern New Hampshire and in western
Maine huge amounts of conservation one
of the places that was most interesting
to see transformed was northern New
Hampshire this is an area with little
conservation that had occurred north of
the White Mountains in 1990 these were
poor rural communities dependent on a
temper economy that was largely
declining and there was in also a strong
suspicion of conservation particularly
from people coming from the south as
well as the north over time you can see
the change that occurred in this place
this is what the world looked like in
1990 dark green preserved light green
working forest and shown in a time
series these are the forest blocks that
were the target of some of T and C and
others work and slowly other preserved
lands were added by 2001 later on more
working forest lands were added and
these are more actually additional
working forest lands and lands that were
certified that was another major
development going on improved forest
management on lands not just protecting
them and then the big protection have
happened up in northern New Hampshire
four percent of the state through a
project that I'll identify in a second
so one of the things that was showcased
by this work that I think is relevant to
our topic was the innovations in
creative financing that have actually
helped to guide transactions today that
I'll touch on at the end they roughly
grouped into these categories of how to
partner with tribe a capital there was a
whole set of innovative deals that
involved teemo's or private timber
investment organizations there was all
kinds of use of foundation program
related investments of loans use of
guarantee
using letters of credit even foundations
helping to subsidize interest rates on
bank debt to enable organizations to do
big deals where they had to borrow even
a debt for nature declining a mill of
land owner who owned a mill and owned
land and there was a swap that refinance
the debt in exchange for an easement
placed on land the use of new markets
tax credits were which were tax credits
that gave in incentives or sweeteners
for investors that invested in projects
in poverty census tracts at the time
land conservation with its public
benefits around jobs qualified for those
tax credits there were four or five
deals that actually used new markets tax
credits I want to talk about just one
project Connecticut lakes this was the
project that I showed you that covered
four percent of northern New Hampshire
the Trust for Public Land bought this
track from IP international paper a
while ago it was four percent 171
thousand acres tpo resold the land to
state and private timber land investors
the land costs 33 million dollars the
division public funds accounted for 13
million of it the t-mo brought 12
million to the picture and philanthropy
including our resources paid for about 8
million there were five other deals that
we helped to support that include this
structure in essence the dark green was
preserved land that was purchased
ultimately by the state of New Hampshire
the light green was the working forest
lands that were owned continued to be
owned by line timber subject to an
easement that was financed with a mix of
public and private money so in this
instance the money was marshalled by
corralling money from the timber
investor and from the NGO and putting it
all together and the NGO worried about
the preserve land and easement but the
timber investor maintained ownership of
that land and this became an effective
model this is a very controversial at
the outset because one had to navigate
traditional interests such as hunting
fishing snowmobiling and some of that
suspicion of conservation that I talk to
you about at the outset so what did we
learn from our work in the northern
forest the northern forest was a great
testing ground for many tools in large
landscape conservation for working out
the science of course buffers and
preserves from working out what a
working for us to easement and a large
scale working for us easement can really
do and how it would be monitored how to
mesh the work of the advocacy
organizations that were finding the
money for these deals with the land
trust that we're actually doing them and
developing partnerships some of which
were rocky with with state and even the
federal government it also was a place
to test theories about forest management
this is illustrated most graphically by
TNCs purchase of land at the very outset
of this phase of land buying of the st.
John lands in northern Maine where it
bought these lands it didn't really have
much idea what it was doing and how to
harvest them but it learned a great deal
from it but more than anything this was
a laboratory for testing financial tools
and practices for the use of debt and
the exploration of new equity
instruments and if anything the question
that we all asked was over and over
again what is the most effective way to
partner with private capital and what
role could philanthropic capital play in
that process for example when you team
up with a team Oh what are the who makes
the rules how much can you ask the
private capital to do how much do you
have to give up if you recall the
Connecticut Lake transaction the t-mo
owns the working forest and you have
your control is exercised through the
easement to own that working for us to
yourself would take a whole lot more
money
a lot of us asked the question could we
become a team could we form a green team
oh how could you cut the t-mo out of out
of the picture and bile and add even a
much cheaper price these are some of the
lessons that we learned about our work
in that region but one of the things I
want to touch on briefly relevant to our
discussion the the northern force
protection fund created many shoots for
OSI including the development of a
community forest fund and various
research projects but one of the main
offshoots was our recognition of the
importance of the larger region and the
connection between the u.s. and Canada
and we created a fund to focus
specifically on protecting land in this
transporter region our work actually
built on analysis and science that had
been conducted that showed key linkages
between the u.s. and Canada in all the
work we did in northern New England and
all the maps we made to look at those
some 20 projects we never once included
anything about canna the map literally
stopped at the Canadian border and so we
knew the country existed but it wasn't
until we began learning about the work
of scientists that were engaged in group
called two countries one for us that we
began to appreciate the relationship
between two countries the group
developed a fair amount of analysis and
mapping called the human footprint and
it highlighted key wildlife linkages
where movement had eat have been
documented or modeled between the two
countries in some instances these were
literal source sync relationships where
an animal might be located in the US but
they were breeding in Canada the links
being one example out of this science
and focused on these linkages we
determined that there was a need to
bring the science down to ground and to
help put tracks into these places
through transactions that could show
people what transporter conservation
really met we created a fun and some of
the results today are the following we
made about 30 grants
almost 2 million dollars evenly split
between the two countries so far 19
projects have closed protecting about
33,000 acres and another nine projects
with about 22,000 acres are on the books
this collectively will leverage about 30
million in principally in public but
some private money with a match of
almost eight nine to one and we are on
track to actually protect about 55,000
acres one of the places where we had the
most impact or have had is in the
northern greens and some of you who work
in northern doing will recognize this
region this is a view looking basically
from the US border north into the Sutton
Mountains which of the Canadian
equivalent of the Greens this is a
region where we have supported a number
of projects that try to build on plans
in the US and in Canada and one of the
things we've done is to convene groups
working on both sides of the border to
try to align those plans and those
strategies and even the communication
about them one of the terrific projects
again the linkage that is shown here in
the northern greens one of the terrific
projects was conducted by the Trust for
Public Land a large tract shown in
orange that connected conservation near
the lands the j state forest onto lands
that have been conserved in canada and
this was a project literally on the
border that illustrated the importance
of transporter conservation in the
following sequence I'm going to
illustrate the effect of some of the
conservation that we've done in about a
six seven year period there's a few
projects missing but basically as you
scroll through this you'll see the big
brown tract is a ten thousand acre tract
that we help to protect through a loan
and more land at being added here you
can see over time there's a landscape
scale impact that is being achieved all
together we have through grants and
loans help too
protect about 4,500 acres that have
closed through the transporter fund
there have been another 13,000 acres
that have been protected through a mix
of grant and loans and there's another
1,200 acres in all about 20,000 acres
will have been protected over about an
eight year period in this area helping
to achieve some of the goals of plans in
these places and to facilitate
connectivity within the Greens between
the u.s. and Canada I want to close with
a couple of observations about two
recent transactions you are looking at
part of some 60,000 67,000 acres of
working for us and preserved lands that
were conserved in northern Wisconsin
through an unusual collaboration between
a timber investment management
organization a national conservation
organization and a public agency and it
was really yet another formulation of
the private capital relationship that
was explored and developed in the
northern forest in particular this deals
historic by Wisconsin standards and
really anybody else's was a 17.3 million
dollar transaction the second largest in
the state of Wisconsin to protect land
right as you can see close to Lake
Superior and in this deal our friend
lime timber again bought seventy two
thousand acres so instead of the NGO
buying it or buying some of it the
private timber organization bought all
of the land for about 37 million and
they secured a loan of 16 million from
the Conservation Fund and they use 21
million of their own funds lime did in
exchange the Conservation Fund secured
an option to basically for an easement
on about 68 70,000 68,000 at that and to
buy 2,000 acres in feet so the option in
return for exchange for giving lime a
preferential loan the Conservation Fund
an option that bought time your so for
the state of Wisconsin to assemble all
the money they needed to buy it as even
on the sixty-eight thousand acres this
is an example of working in a creative
way with the t-mo some ways the t-mo has
the upper hand here as opposed to in the
northern forests of reflection perhaps
of the diminished state of public
funding that the NGO has access to and
yet a conservation outcome and a
significant one at scale was still
secured through this innovative
arrangement where GCF used its
concessionary capital in this case
low-cost loan funds to effect a
significant conservation outcome there's
another deal that some of you if there's
any of people from the West that are on
this phone that will recognize this may
well be the most important transaction
of our generation this is certainly one
of the biggest and it is certainly one
of the most significant in Tennessee's
history this is a hundred and thirty
four million dollar deal to protect
165,000 acres of land in the Cascade
Mountain Range Washington and the
Blackfoot River Valley in Montana as you
can see here and this essentially is
being dubbed the checkerboard project
again for folks who know this in the
West the checkerboard results from the
granting of railroads land within 10 to
40 miles of a railroad right away while
enabling the federal government to
obtain neighboring sections within that
assemblage with the result that you get
this checkerboard that results in
fragmentation potential development and
has potentially harmful effects for
ecological integrity in these national
forests 47 thousand acres in the yakima
river headwaters in washington on the
last one hundred and seventeen thousand
acres in the lower Blackfoot River
watershed in Montana on the right you're
seeing a view of catch list lake and
i-90 in though in the distance this is a
spectacular landscape that connects
federal and state wilderness areas
this is the yakima which is a site for
salmon and steelhead spawning and it's
within just a little more than an hour's
drive of Seattle looking at the Swan
range and photos leading up to the
whiskey or dredge but that's the snowy
rich in the risin this is an area that's
popular for recreation near Missoula
known for vast forests and trout rivers
and also ranching some of the valleys so
the terms of the deal are most
interesting T&C bought it outright 434
million the wii's foundation put up
ninety percent of that money 120 million
dollars in the form of a preferred
preferred equity with a four percent
dividend so this is not a philanthropic
investment this is an investment or a
programming investment the remainder of
the funding was secured through an eight
million dollar PRI from the Packard
Foundation and other philanthropic
donations now TMC doesn't know the exact
disposition of all this land though most
will eventually be sold or transferred
into public ownership it will have to
repay wiese and packard through revenues
on sustainable little timbering and
revenue from other ecosystem services
this is an interesting deal certainly it
showcases a new model for engaging
private capital T and C having secured
it from an angel but an investor and it
resent represents a considerable advance
in the model that was developed in the
northern forest where we typically or
the group's there had to rely on a more
collaborative model engaging side by
side private capital here tnc secured
that capital and and stepped up and now
controls the land and Ken and has much
more control over the disposition has a
lot more risk because it has to manage
the repayment of those loans and those
and those investors and so this this is
a challenging highly highly challenging
situation but one of the things this
deal does and the note I want to end on
is that it does signal the opportunity
for a new class of
capital impact investments are the rage
they're the subject of panels
discussions and conferences the large
investment banks are very interested in
exploring ways reports have been
released of documenting the huge amount
of capital that would like to be
deployed into conservation and the
environment for modest return and the
challenge now is to find deal and that
will be a challenge indeed because a
deal can absorb private capital only if
it creates return and return has created
through timber harvesting sale of carbon
or other revenues and that creates
challenges for conservation they can't
always be achieved and I think it's
important to recognize both the huge
opportunity to steal signals and also
the challenges it represents with that I
think I'll end and turn it back to you
Andrew great thank you so much for your
presentation Peter we have some
questions from the audience and
colleagues that we would love your input
on so as you know the open space
institute's conservation finance program
provides grants and low-cost loans to
small and medium-sized land trusts the
program provides a source of capital
that a lot of fledgling land trust would
otherwise have difficulty acquiring yet
at the same time from a financial point
of view there's that inherent risk of
lending capital to land trusts that
don't have an established track record
how then does OSI balance considerations
of risk with the conservation potential
well it's a great question great
question because our goal is not not
necessarily to meet reach the smallest
of the small but we certainly see a
niche for ourselves to help emerging and
even regional land trust and indeed the
majority of our grants over the last six
years have gone actually the mid-size
any and even regional land Trust's to
risk question yes we make grants and
invest in projects where there is a
strong likelihood that they'll be
completed so the feasibility is a big
part of our analysis and we we have to
be assured that there's a reasonable
likelihood that deals will get done we
have taken on more risk making earlier
commitments to land trusts and giving
them for example time periods to
assemble resources or to demonstrate
that they're on track to receive public
and nonprofit fundings so we have we are
I think taking a little bit more risk on
projects we still want to see projects
that come to us with a fair degree of
planning with a strong likelihood of
being great thank you so much we have a
question from cecilia from the audience
you touched on this in one of your case
studies but would you be able to give us
a general idea of the level of returns
that private investors expect from these
investments sure well there's a huge
range there's a there's you know I
mentioned that the wii's Foundation put
up money asking for basically a four
percent dividend and and that's that's
fairly reasonable I think you'll find
some investors individuals or
foundations that will look to make loans
of less than that in particular since
with interest rates very very low right
now and they're fixed income investments
yielding often less than a percent
investors may not be demanding too much
so the range really is you know I think
between foundations that you can get to
invest and make loans it's sort of one
percent to equity investments that could
range more from four to six or seven
percent but at six or seven percent
that's pretty that's pretty deer and and
it really you know it depends a lot on
the asset class there are some timos
that were accustomed to making eight and
twelve percent or even higher fifteen
percent though
those returns have have have declined
recently just with overall declines in
the asset class so there's a really big
big range wow that's quite something so
during in the presentation you touched
on the lessons learned from partnering
with private institutions like teemo's
and the conservation compromises that
arise from those partnerships how
realistic do you think it is for the
creation of a green tea MO as you
mentioned to serve that function and
would you consider the new model
demonstrated by TNC and partners on the
deal in Montana as filling this role I
think it is in essence i think TNC has
finally surmounted that challenge we
struggled with in the northern forests
of the side by side and found a way with
a very you know oh thank thanks to a big
investor it found a way to actually
create a version of the Green Team oh I
i want to say also that the Conservation
Fund is to be credited they also have a
working forest fond and internal fund
that functions somewhat like a green
team oh and I you know my my sense is it
that that these are versions of green
teemo's they're not the question of
whether these organizations want to do
it at the scale with the intensity that
an actual chemo desert where they have a
fund and they're putting money into 10
projects all over the country or in
different parts of the world in some
ways you have to work at scale it would
with an investment fund to earn enough
to justify fees and pay salaries and
expenses and my sense is that I don't
think that either TNC or GCF wants to
get into that business quite in that
same way and so this may be more of
almost like a jury-rigged model or an
experiment on on its way toward some
other final resolution for those of you
who know TMZ and and there's hats off to
tnc for the
this project but they have created an
entity called nature vest that may have
been the subject of an earlier webinar
or should be as a vehicle to try to
leverage increased investments for a
series of projects so it's not exactly a
team oh it's a nonprofit and it's more
of a kind of a fundraising arm but I
guess the question of your aunt the
answer your question andrew is in effect
I think we do have versions of green tea
Mose that that these transactions
illustrate that's quite encouraging I
was we'd like to move into the area of
conservation and how it relates to
climate change as you move forward with
pursuing land acquisition to create
conservation quarters how is your team
considering challenges presented by
climate change ensuring that your
projects contribute towards climate
change resilience well it's a it's
topical and I didn't show slides on it
and I could show a million slides on it
but our our resilient landscape
initiative is focused on precisely that
challenge and we are as i mentioned
utilizing science developed by TNC that
identifies resilient landscapes those
that have the ability to facilitate
wildlife adaptation as the climate warms
and becomes wetter the science is is
based on identifying places that are
both complex that have a diversity of
landforms elevational gradients and
connected places that are both complex
and allow species to find refuge either
up or down or sideways as as as things
get warmer and wetter and at the same
time they're big enough landscapes
they're connected and unfragmented that
they can move through those complex
landscapes so thanks to this science
we've identified across the East and our
initial focus areas that I showed on one
slide are a stab at identifying some
initial places that could be good
testing grounds for what it means to be
a resilient Lansky
there is also some interesting analysis
we're mulling and the TNC is working on
that looks at broader connectivity
corridors between these resilient nodes
that may be places that would facilitate
large-scale movement and we're working
on bringing that to ground and figuring
out what that means but I think kind of
change does pose a very significant
challenge for land Trust's because we
can't just protect the places that we
think are resilient today or that we
that have biodiversity today we have to
be thinking about where are those places
that will retain or attract biodiversity
tomorrow and that is a huge first order
question hmm going into the interaction
with communities in your presentation
you highlighted the importance of
building reputation and Trust over
extended periods of time how do you
balance this need though to establish
credibility over time with the urgency
to prevent development in key ecosystems
wow it's a great question because in an
ideal world you want to move at the
speed at which development is moving and
yet sometimes that speed goes faster
than the rate at which you can bring
along community so that is the challenge
now typically where development threats
are really impending upon you that is
often the place where with effective
outreach you can mobilize the community
communities get mobilized by development
threads so sometimes you can manage
these processes simultaneously one of
the things that really the economic
downturn real estate downturn since 09
has given us all in this community is a
little breathing room the developers are
not knocking down our doors that where
they were in 07 and 08 and and and the
threat gives us the chance to think not
just about necessity but about
opportunity and and it gives us time to
develop the support that we need for
those transactions so in some ways I
think the downturn has been one solution
to the problem that you mentioned
so for our last question for the session
I was wondering if you could talk about
landscape scale conservation in other
regions of the United States and are you
familiar with other work being done in
other areas and if so could you discuss
the nuances between conservation efforts
in different regions in terms of
political climate funding sources or
anything and everything sure well
resource and we could easily make it
available to folks and some probably
participated is that there's an enormous
amount of work being done in the
academic community right now to
chronicle and distill and synthesize the
work across the country of various large
scale large landscape scale efforts
conference in DC organized by jim
leavitt up at harvard went a long way
toward distilling that there's material
on the web there's folks out at the
University of Montana Matt McKinney who
has done a terrific amount of work with
this generally the work distributes
between landscape scale efforts focused
in more rural places where biodiversity
or large scale recreational access of
the sort the gunks is an example or you
have various metropolitan even urban
landscape scale efforts urban greenways
the Chicago wilderness being example of
that so it's hard I think it's hard to
generalize but a couple of quick
observations on some of the most
successful landscape well it's the kind
of the granddaddy of the effort is the Y
to Y effort out west that is now 20 25
years and it's making that preceded with
a plan that everybody thought was
implemented and has slowly implemented
land protection really from you know
Yellowstone all the way up through
Canada into Alaska and that is sort of
the model for efforts around the country
a couple quick observations you know
successful effort
benefit from strong planning and an
incorporation of good science they can
make a compelling an intellectually
defensible argument not just we've got
to connect things for connecting sake or
protect things for protecting say second
process outreach to engage constituents
and beneficiaries in those regions is
another really really essential
component third funding being able to
put things on the ground that can be the
proof of concept and engage further
funding that that's another really
really essential effort as opposed to
efforts that stay purely in a kind of
planning or mapping mode those that
actually put tracks on the ground and
can show people what success looks like
weather strikes me is three really
powerful a fourth I would argue in
something we've realized in the gunks is
that when you can connect the
conservation work you're doing to other
agendas whether it be economic
recreational agendas you gain so much
more power and legitimacy the YY effort
is even realize that so to me those are
four components of success at the
landscape scale when you ask me you know
where our successful efforts I could go
on and on to me one of the most
successful is an old one and the ace
basin I think some of the efforts in New
England that that I touched on briefly
the regional conservation partnerships
at smaller scale whether it's the egg
amenities to the sea or the mount khwab
robin de cardigan club and a cardigan
effort these are these are some ranging
in size very very successful efforts and
there are many more those are great
components to end on and that concludes
the talk on landscape scale conservation
in the United States once again we would
like to thank Peter Howell for joining
us today if you wish to review a
recording of this webinar please visit
the Yale Center for business and the
environment website or access the
recording
through the Yale iTunes University
podcast thank you for joining us until
next time this is andrew woo from the
yield center for business and
environment